la proposition a surpris jusque dans les
coulisses du pouvoir à Washington la
Pologne propose d'offrir sa trentaine
d'avions de combat amic-29 à l'Ukraine
en passant par les États-Unis
nous sommes prêts à donner la totalité
de notre flotte d'avion de combat à la
base américaine de Rammstein mais nous
ne sommes pas prêts à faire quoi que ce
soit par nous-mêmes
ces avions pourraient ensuite être
déployés par les États-Unis en Ukraine
en échange la Pologne recevrait des FCS
d'occasion de la part de Washington mais
au Pentagone on freine les quatre fers
pour éviter de se retrouver piégé dans
un engrenage militaire nous ne pensons
pas que la proposition de la Pologne
soit viable la perspective d'avion de
combat partant d'une base États-Unis au
temps en Allemagne pour voler vers un
espace aérien disputé avec la Russie
au-dessus de l'Ukraine suscite de
sérieuses préoccupations pour l'ensemble
de l'OTAN
l'Ukraine a multiplié les appels aux
occidentaux pour qu'il lui fournissent
militaire afin de faire face à
l'invasion russe mais un tel geste
ferait des États-Unis ou de tout pays
aux Françaises avions déco belligérants
or Washington et l'OTAN ont indiqué
clairement à plusieurs reprises qu'ils
n'entrerait pas dans un conflit direct
avec Moscou